i think this is maybe another
this is rev tracy g i think this is
another gang stalking person
so if that is the case let me see here
i watch a lot of television
i mean like habitual
television i don't mean like
let's sit down every day at a certain
time and watch
tv i mean like i had
absolutely nothing no one to depend on
the only constant in my life from the
time i was born was television
it was scheduled it was regular
when it wasn't it was devastating but
that has a lot to do with
more of my brain function than
anything else
but something that i've noticed and i've
known since i was small
and also i've read in sacred text but i
i refer to christianity because that's
the one that's been
in me
since the beginning of time
but i refer back to that that we're
finding principalities and spirits that
are greater than our
mind derp utter
every sacred text tells you that
so anytime a group of people
doesn't matter what group a group of
animals let's say
monkeys even lions doesn't matter
group of animals generally ones that
have an aggressive
leader squirrels squirrels are huge
with this but human beings
once one group says i've had enough of
this behavior
and they just rise up like a volcano
well they rise up like a volcano and
they go blah
okay oh my god hold on a second
she's not wrong about the squirrel thing
she is not wrong
check this out
this is crazy she's not lying
weird this looks like our neighborhood
and that looks like my house
yeah but it's got some fat kid in the
window
check this out sir the president's been
killed
oh my god so what's our next move
mr president
there's going to be some changes around
here
oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you want to laugh at her all laugh
at her all you want
but was she wrong word who gives a [ __ ]
anymore because i found out the more i
rely on what i said and how i said it
the less the message
comes so i just have to be free flow
well i can't because it's been [ __ ]
ingrained in me
slow slow
takeover nazis came in and did it
robbing
well america's coming into this slow
[Music]
slow and steady wins the race and then
you get white people that are
weird-looking
too many people trying to make us
perfect
or not or crazy somebody stole
little people and took their magic and
now you got people that have
um overgrowth
lateral overgrowth syndrome like me
which can be any hyperplasia or any
okay look she sounds like
like a villain you know like like like a
villain
saying their their plot
right no tell me i'm wrong tell me she
doesn't sound like a villain
hold on
this might be better for her than that
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
well they rise up like a volcano and
they go blah
okay and they devastate things around
them and they act words ate
but that's the right word who gives a
[ __ ] anymore because i found out the
more i rely on
what i said and how i said it the less
the message comes
so i just have to be free flow well i
can't because it's been [ __ ]
ingrained in me
[Music]
slow
wins the race and then you get white
people that are weird-looking
too many people trying to make us
perfect
or not or crazy somebody stole little
people
and took their magic and now you've got
people that have um
overgrowth lateral overgrowth syndrome
like me
which can be any hyperplasia or any um
whatever the [ __ ] anyway there's a whole
bunch of studies you go on my website
you'll find it
but anyhow it's a group of people's blah
right
devastating
and then
when with the devastation that has
happened
but the people do not change
they just get buried
and then they rise up these flowers
you know first first ones that come
through are
the beneficial ones like dandelions and
attention
and that's when the poison what's going
on
i pretty much start popping out
and the poison coming in so you got
raw coming out
okay i'm going to use white people as an
example
europe bra
what is it um there's no place on earth
no place of the light
the sun doesn't go down on england or
whatever i don't know
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] okay they own
everything
the opponents they
killed everyone
[Music]
thank you
they sliced and diced you and made you
become whatever catholic religion
okay i'm included i'm i'm of dramatic
history and that's a whole other issue
so you got this this group of people
that comes up and blonde
and then they're devastated the volcanic
and voila
all right and then and okay so the weeds
come through that earth and then nobody
wants you around kind of stomp one out
over here and then of course you know
that's when the pretty ones come through
and they're toxic
but they're pretty and they're enticing
everything just keeps getting covered up
and exploding and
humanity has not learned from this
we come in the form of people you don't
want to look at
jay-z knight not a beautiful woman
actually i'm a very attractive man
and i think it's because jay-z knight
channels the spirit
i don't she says it's a chinese warrior
i don't give a [ __ ]
what it is it's not the man it's not the
woman it's the message
the rant that is a message very similar
to
christ and bob marley and bill higgs
bob marley came at it with love and
force
very similar to mine which is you know
of course respect
existence or expect
resistance i
i firmly believe that you either ex you
either respect that i exist
or i'm gonna fight you
you either respect that black people are
a person or i'm gonna fight you
you understand
you better respect the trans people
whether you're black or white you matter
black people got it worse because black
community you can't have mental health
you can't be you can't
be anything and you can't deviate from
the norm
and this is ingrained this is
ingrained from the king
in africa i mean i'm telling the white
king in africa i'm telling you this is
ingrained in them
beating into them i know because i also
have things beaten in my correct speech
which makes my face
really bad because i get stuck you know
directly i lose a message like right now
the message is
no lives matter
it's all the same from animals to human
bra and then blend and peace for a
minute
until all these little things come and
then you notice they're actually
connected and then it's
blah over here then you just have blah
everywhere and it's ridiculous
i beg of you looking
to explode quit coming with
anger quit fighting everything
and come up like a dandelion strong
connect it
easily blown away in the wind to grow
again like a phoenix
okay
okay or if you like a
mushroom [ __ ] investigate on
investigate a mushroom
be like a mushroom go up here and have a
little root
system under here it goes across the
entire earth
but i'm telling you don't rather gather
in big groups
you guys haven't learned anarchy is the
best
one person see the change
is here and now you beg to stay home now
you're staying home
you beg to have more time with your
family now you have it now you don't
want it
bob marley said how can you say you love
me
you don't love all of me you say you
love the rain that you
won't go out without an umbrella and a
coat
how can you say you love the rain if you
don't go dancing
how can you say you love the sun if you
don't go out in it and let it burn your
skin once in a while
you cannot love it if you don't love all
of it
you have to love humanity go ahead to
bed
the orange demigod
that you have to love all of humanity
because if you don't love humanity
how how
are you gonna get through here
without dying
peace love joy blessed me
i
i don't know
i don't i don't know what to say
i i don't know
what to say oh there's the link
um her name is rev tracy g
this was look normally you know people
say i pau
i i didn't want to stop i couldn't
i was i was were you
i'm sorry i know i should have paused
and commented but i was actually just
mesmerized
this was a villain speech from a [ __ ]
movie
[Music]
this was a villain speech from a movie
dude i'm not putting excuse me oh you
draw i'm not putting this on this isn't
me
putting this on that was one of the
scariest
most hypnotizing things
i've ever seen in my life
she this video has three views
three this video has
three views and she may be a super
[Music]
villain
and when the video was cutting out
holy [ __ ]
i feel uncomfortable i i actually feel
uncomfortable
we need to stop her at all cause
[ __ ] get batman on the phone because
this is a problem
this is a problem and god forbid this
woman ever gets money
or power we're all [ __ ]
[Music]
we're all [ __ ]